over time overseas Jane does the US do
more harm or good with its drone policy
um the use of domestic drones is doing a
lot of harm
by the way domestic I don't ask a
question I know but let me go to both
parts we're not really killing people
with this well we that's a possibility I
think it's really out of control and
we're gonna shred our fourth amendment
you heard it here the use of drones
internationally is a mixed bag and we
should reduce the use of drones and our
foreign policy should be much much more
about economic trade and aid and helping
educate people all over the world so
they have opportunities on balance I was
a supporter of the drone program I
believe today it is doing more harm than
good
overseas the reason is is because we are
it's the sole tool basically of our war
on terrorism when we take out al Qaeda
safe houses we wind up taking out the
spouses and the children hundreds
sometimes thousands of people have been
killed over the years in places like
Yemen and Somalia and Pakistan and we we
generate this resentment from these
populations for that and we also lose
valuable intelligence because instead of
capturing these guys and getting
information out of them to prevent a
future attack we wind up vaporizing them
we vaporizes them and their entire
community so you would agree with what I
was just saying it's because we're there
if we weren't there no shall we be there
it means how we're there America has an
empire we don't have an empire yeah we
don't have an EM you're having and we're
America before today we may be bill
it'll it would not before not have so I
just in like a hundred and fifty
different countries in the world are you
crazy we have like seven hundred and
sixteen bases
fifteen thousand troops in Germany I
think we got it under light now - it's
the bike by 2013 there's no single
American tank in Europe and by the way
if you were you're praising Obama's you
know peace record because of this week
policy now he had no choice but to bring
American soldiers a small detachment
hundred soldiers at 10 tanks at the
Russian border first time in my living
memory American troops are facing
Russian troops in Estonia Latvia because
it's that those small countries are
neighed members and by 2013 they were no
American tension at all wake me when he
takes Poland anyway I mean yes we move
to hunt you make the jokes about it yes
obviously that was just post suffered
from at I hope now personally it's a
comedy show Gary we make jokes about
everything okay if I have to watch out
the coastal it's not about the outdoors
you made it about the Holocaust but for
poles is tough for poles it's to
millions of poles have been killed by
Russians and Germans Gary shut up this
is a stupid thing to say I'm sorry I'm a
big fan of yours but to say that I was
making a holocaust joke when I said wake
me when you play jokes about everything
I do but that was not a holocaust joke
and I don't think I've ever made one now
I'm a good time for a [ __ ]
talk about the Obama model versus the
Bush model right the four-year
anniversary of us getting bin Laden was
fantastic
and yet after that President Obama said
al Qaeda is on the run al Qaeda has been
decimated Wow look at Yemen look at
Somalia look at Nigeria look at what's
going on throughout the Middle East
terrorism is not on the whole it hasn't
are denim 8003 well we should never have
gotten there that may or may not be I'm
simply celebrating we're celebrating a
SEAL team operation that took out a took
out bin Laden as though that is the that
is the strategy that can solve our
problems around the world that's the
model I think it's no sorry
in 2003 there were attacks on the Cole
and there were attacks in around the
Middle East in the 90s and we didn't see
the signals in it's 93 wait wait that's
right what well I think what we were
saying there is that the model of going
after terrorism as a law enforcement and
spy agency issue as opposed to sending
invading armies into Arab lands is the
MA let me say can by the way that is the
model because Iraq didn't make us safer
in any way every time we've stopped a
terrorist attack it's because they did
some good police work we were able to
get bin Laden for two reasons one we
captured a lot of bad guys and got
information out of them in ways that
made people like you uncomfortable and
second of all we present I had a
presence in the middlee you're saying
what like a fact and it is hardly I'm
happy to debate it with you and we had a
presence in the Middle East that got us
a lot of human intelligence the
cumulative effect this is which allows
us allows us to do a lot of things like
the bin Laden operation not like we just
send a team in and they go and don't
make it out we secured democracy for the
Middle East after that 9 2003 was a
great victory of course we didn't do
that
and how to believe intelligence on Iraq
I did and I was wrong and going into
Iraq was wrong but we've done a lot of
things right there are three they're
looking for the three countries is a
rock where we went in big and it's a
mess
they're Syria where we actually
deliberately stayed out of it starting
in 2011 there's chemical weapons being
used against Syrians hundreds of
thousands of people are dead more than a
million are displaced
there's Libya where we went in and got
right out and left it open and now it's
completely being taken over by militant
Islamists so the idea that us just going
into Iraq is a model for disaster is
absurd now there are places where we
haven't engaged at all that are on fire
right now didn't cost us American lives
and trillions of dollars there's always
going to be places in the world that are
on fire yeah but we're arguing two
different things I'm simply saying what
Joe is saying is we went in and we got a
mess and I mean angry when we know
there's a mess there are places we
haven't touched and they were even more
of a mess but don't don't you think that
the people in the Middle East have to
have a war amongst themselves some of
them want to live they are money free
all right now and some of them want to
live in the seconds yeah you know what
you know they need to have that out they
are having a flower it is happening look
what's happening in Yemen right now all
right it's it's basically a Shiite Sunni
proxy war sure the Saudis right I mean
one side maybe the Iranians are meeting
the other well guess what President
Obama just signed this this framework
agreement with Iran that will give Iran
a nuclear program we can debate how
quickly it'll make a nuclear bomb finish
let me finish but they got a nuclear
program the Saudis are already saying
all right well if the Iranians get one
we get one and the cutter aides are
saying the same thing and the Egyptians
the Turks aren't going to be far behind
so you want that Sunni Shiite civil war
in the region fine guess what it's about
to be thrown in nuclear arms race isn't
about to be thrown into the mix when all
these countries that's a lot of leaps
leap it's a sit there saying that right
now your bodies are saying
you left from Obama's Iran treaty to
Iran has a nuclear weapon now nowadays
from Iran a Burley's announcement of his
deal to what the Saudis and the Qatar
E's are saying in response now they're
saying if you're going to legitimize
Iran's nuclear program we get one too
but there's not much it amazing is how
is he not you say he sees their nuclear
program he's program clear website
nuclear profit right time and so the
Saudis are gonna start saying great we
get one - okay but a nuclear program is
not nuclear weapon and he's quickly with
a little bit of our D becomes an agility
much more quickly become one if we don't
have the inspectors in there we have
first on United States president raised
the issue about Iranian nuclear problem
it was Bill Clinton in 1995 asking Boris
Yeltsin to stop supplying Iran was
Russian nuclear technology Yeltsin gave
him very vague promise and Clinton
hasn't pushed 20 years ago American
American president already knew about
the potential problem but yet we
actually will Congress tried to block
that we did try and Clinton vetoed it as
I remember and I think we passed it over
his veto you are you said something that
I shocked to believe I kind of agree
with you on okay I mean it's I'm still
it's like I'm hallucinating here but you
said you said it wouldn't it be great if
we had inspectors in there to prevent
Iran from getting its breakout nuclear
weapons capability I I completely agree
the problem is the Iranians don't agree
right
the commander hold on the commander of
the Revolutionary Guard Corps in Iran
has said you cannot inspect military
facilities in Iran yet that's to win his
base that's the Tea Party of Iraq
that doesn't mean that's what the final
deal is that you know tell me what the
deal is the moment the moment the u.s.
you know make it maybe they were in the
moment the u.s. came out the p5 plus one
came out with its interim agreement the
foreign minister of Iran said that fact
sheet is spinach out real the Supreme
Leader of Iran said sanctions were
removed right away not the way President
Obama saying let's go Birdo okay so yes
there
like them there's like a Persian version
of this document and then there's an
American version of it and they're not
do isn't cut and if there is no deal the
other five of the p5 plus one are going
to walk away from the sanctions and
trade with Iran and there will be an
arms race in the Middle East and the
hope is that it will be a good enough
deal and we'll all stick together and
one of the other beneficiaries of a good
enough deal even though they don't see
it that way yet is Israel I have I have
I would love a good deal I do not think
this is a good deal and if and I think
we could get a better deal this deal was
negotiated when a carranza economy was
was strangled and oil was being traded
at $100 a barrel to there today it's
under $50 a barrel they're under more
economic pressure we can go to the chin
all right I don't think so
yesterday isn't hearing somebody who was
so wrong about a war let you about
what's going on now like Kim Kardashian
telling you how to be a wife it's kind
of like that
I just know there's so many mistakes
were made and they will argue just like
with so many points and facts and
figures and it was so wrong headed that
we will suffer for that for for decades
and and how do you are you so you you
all speak with such certainty and if you
were right then we wouldn't be in this
situation we are in now right I mean I
could ask you the same question I asked
professor Stiglitz out there I mean 60
billion was the estimate from Rumsfeld
and and George Bush and it's costing
over 4 trillion dollars what else can
you be that wrong about where else can
you be even close to that you can say
we've won the war against al-qaeda when
we have it Wow is that really that's
above you it's a big deal I don't know
if it's comparable it's a big deal Wow
but did you know that it's not
comparable it's so no it's just what he
said it's not money it's not lives it's
just a guy actually is lives no no
things going on in Syria now but we
wouldn't think this war is over hundreds
of thousands of people slaughtered your
chemical weapon is arguing the red team
is not really really what you I'm just
you're just I mean this is your team
this is what's wrong with America what
nobody ever argues the trimmer'
this is my team
position hey I'm the first to admit
because I saw it firsthand that our
country and the Bush administration made
huge mistakes huge in the Gulf War I
mean huge so and I was advocating for
things and others who will work with me
were advocating for things that
frustratingly our government didn't do
to fix things alright we finally did
turn things around gradually but to
suggest that this is just some partisan
talking point is a little absurd to
suggest that it's equally a mistake to
send thousands of people to their death
yeah cost trillions of dollars with a
president prematurely saying that this
one terrorist group is on the run and
they're simply saying it's just absurd
it's absurd and you know that it's a
James not on the red team so I'm but I
take you well a little bit I'm trying to
get these things trying to help get
these things right I think it's a
dangerous world I agree with what Gary
said about Putin I think if people don't
stand up to Putin what what lesson are
we not learning we have to stand up to
Putin and we have to figure out a way to
help and if you happen sanction is what
about giving these weapons to the
Iranian clear that that well by the way
I work more harder Senate unanimously
supported you know almost all Democrats
you know and Republicans support arming
Ukraine by the way in 1994 I'm the
pressure from Bill Clinton Ukraine has
been disarmed Ukraine had the third
largest nuclear arsenal the world bigger
than China France and UK combined right
us demanded this Arsenal to be this to
be dismantled you can give it up for the
guarantees of its territorial integrity
it's a signature of US president and by
the way UK Prime Minister I mean it's
you have to stand by your signature but
would it be better if all the former
Soviet republics had nuclear weapons in
them if not
not it was a good idea that they did it
but they were guarantees in exchange for
for removing them back to Russia okay
well well I take your your point
seriously why can't anybody here talk
with certainty about what should happen
in the world Assessors like as well
absolutely
I don't absolute I don't think there are
any I think there are the least least
bad options in a lot of these places
there are no agreement good options and
figuring out a way forward is important
but this is a point that I where maybe
we disagree bill I think withdrawing
from all this and letting them all fight
it out and seeing where it ends up is is
not something we should do I think
America's responsibility oh I know how
to fight it out with each other but we
should get them out at all so there
would be my comment I think we should I
mean we are not the indispensable power
where the indispensable partner in the
world we have wealth we have history
really have stopped thinking of
ourselves as so [ __ ] indispensable I
you know what is ready we're not that
into ourselves okay we should go a
little back I don't think our but that's
what is it beautiful I always the most
exception I don't think we should live
without us maybe they can talk sure
better service minister people are
willing to you to enter America why
what's that why millions of tens of
millions of you in the world are trying
to enter United States
I'm not saying other countries aren't
bigger shitholes I'm saying why do we
have to go there I think our influence
would be a lot greater if we actually
fixed America more right hands
Emily usage
opportunity call this point if we took
that four trillion dollars and just the
infrastructure ours our country is
crumbling do believe it would go to
infrastructure stock markets well we
have a choice we have a choice yeah
system our political system hasn't been
working the right way but and that's
partly because the Republicans really
you know it's interesting job you know
it's interesting job that it's a
democratic White House that feels so
strongly about maintaining a federal
guarantee for our big investment banks
and so if they ever implode again
the taxpayers have to bail them out and
I am poor completely untangling that
guarantee a lot of Republicans are I
agree with you on that I mean that that
was a big mistake the way we bailed out
the banks we had to save the banks but
we didn't have to save the bankers the
shareholders in the Bible so let us
living that okay it's not it's not
Republicans in the white house we're
holding all the waiters say they are
investment banking lobbyists they're
very close to this administration
they're making sure that guarantees but
decisions like cities because no-brainer
is a no-brainer and and let's be honest
when when Obama was trying to get the
economy back on its feet he begged the
Republican Congress to spend some money
on infrastructure he said look we have
millions of people out of work
they could fix this it's a it's a we can
borrow my job and control of the
Congress in the first year of
administration no event we did Ortiz in
the house in the Senate and he got a
stimulus a trillion dollar stimulus
right he got dodd-frank pass which which
has a too big to fail guarantee built in
to protect the investment banks he got
Obamacare passed he got a bunch of
things passed so why didn't he push
exactly what you're saying well he was
working on those first you're correct
and a lot of people said he should work
on the economy first and he said you
know what America is quitting is
infrastructure
what's its infrastructure you know the
loss we share the last
construction of the East River New York
was in 1909 right we're agreeing
shocking
yes and that and if people go across
that bridge and they die it'll be a
holocaust oh I didn't mean it
way okay so my point is yes a lot of
people said he should work on the
economy first and I think what he was
saying is our healthcare system is the
economy and it is because we have that
was everybody agreed before he did
health care everybody agreed that this
is a thing that's going to break the
budget remember where the curve was
going now we have Obamacare and it
bended the curve and we're not going to
go broke because that good I never
bought that argument I don't know about
what you think about this prevents I
never bought that argument that by doing
health care he wasn't doing the economy
by doing health care he was doing the a
but there's more people than there were
when Obama came down there be more
people was hopping out of the layer that
was because he was out there there was
30 years of deregulation and I you know
it was bipartisan but there were 30
years of mistaken policies that began
under Reagan but got worse and worse and
worse and and the result of that is in
2008 we had ages for the ODA Jamie be
very clear versus also Bill Clinton my
Bridal bite just in the audit when you
mentioned Reagan I just want to make
sure they know that Clinton and the
economy went into the deepest downturn
that we had in 80 years and we pull back
now but it wasn't done as well as it
could have been actually had the right
investment but it would have been a lot
you know I think he had hoped that if
the economy didn't turn around and when
it came to 2011 we would have another
dose I thought that was a political
misjudgment in 2011 he didn't he no
longer controlled Congress he couldn't
get the second dose of the economy
needed of stimulus and that's why we've
had a lingering recovery with 91% of the
benefits going to the
for 1% but it was a problem that was
presented to him unfortunately by in
2009 a t' alright I think everyone's
talked out thank you ladies
you